hey what's up guys my name is the China
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we started our 2d renderer is
all very exciting make sure that you
check out that video if you haven't
already and today I got a haircut
let's get that away and second of all
we've got a very simple goal in mind as
to what we're doing today we're going to
be continuing on our 2d renderer and
we're going to just make it so that we
can actually set the position and size
of our rectangle currently we can render
a rectangle in our 2d renderer it's all
very exciting but that quad that we're
rendering is in a fixed position it's
basically whatever data is inside that
vertex buffer that's where it gets
rendered but obviously in a real-world
scenario and judging by the parameters
we've written for a drawcord function we
want to be able to set the position and
size in other words the transform of our
actual rectangles that's what we're
going to be talking about today super
hot today
Australian summers coming
so transforms transforms are a very
important concept of course full game
edges and games in general whenever you
want to render something on the screen
or just track the position of something
you'll likely be using transforms and
transforms of course are kind of a
compound of the translation the rotation
and the scale usually in that order kind
of TRS translation rotation scale you
hear that a lot and the way that we're
going to be achieving this without
simple 2d renderer is very well simple
we're just going to be setting up a
matrix that we send into our shader via
a uniform per draw pool and that's going
to determine the transform of our
rectangle however I don't necessarily
want to take in a whole matrix as a
transform usually when you're drawing
quads just like we are here we have a
very simple API but we simply might be
specifying like a two component vector
as the actual position and same for the
size right so we have two floats to
determine the size two floats to
determine the position rotation might be
something we consider as well in the
future that's you know you can extend
the API to do that but for now we're
just going to be focusing on these two
it's really not that difficult in fact
you guys could probably do something
like that for homework if you wanted to
in fact yes we're gonna add position and
size but you guys are gonna
look at adding rotation the other big
problem that we have right now as I'm
looking through this card is that well
it's not really a problem it's just more
of an annoyance and that is the fact
that anytime we want to set a uniform in
our shader at the moment we actually
have to use the OpenGL shader API
specifically because the shader API
doesn't actually have any functions to
set uniforms because in the future as I
explained it's usually going to be
handled by a material system will be
sent will be setting entire buffers
instead of individual variables but for
now I think it's reasonable for us to
extend the API so that we can set
individual uniforms I think that's
something that in the future will be
good for debugging anyway like if
something is not working or if we want
to force something for any kind of
circumstance maybe for debug purposes it
would be nice to be able to be like you
know materials aside I want to forcibly
set this particular uniform variable to
be a certain value and that's final so
because of that we're going to be
introducing an API in this video as well
so that we can do that and that should
be relatively simple but first I want to
thank all the patrons that made this
series possible patreon home for such
the channel is the best way to help
support this series and everything that
I'm doing here on YouTube as a reward
for helping to support this series
you'll get access to a much more
advanced code base of the hazel engine
which has like 3d rendering animation
that kind of stuff already implemented
so if you're interested in that you
don't want to do 2d rendering then
definitely check that out and help
support this series okay so step one fix
up this shader API I wanted to make it
so that we don't have to dynamic casts
to an OpenGL shader whenever we want to
set a uniform and then we're just gonna
be adding basically transforms into our
2d renderer so that we can actually
render our quads at different locations
and sizes let's do it okay so step one
is as I mentioned and this is what we
did last time we added this little to-do
basically telling ourselves that we
should add a set map for setfloat or
that kind of stuff here so that we don't
actually have to do this and if we take
a look at our 2d renderer all right here
it is render a 2d LCVP you can see that
we're including OpenGL shader and then
we're doing all this dynamic car stuff
not really ideal not something that I
want to do at all so what I'm going to
do is just remove this we shouldn't be
including that any
we're and then we just need to make this
work basically and that should not be
too difficult at all so what I'm gonna
do is basically change this API around a
little bit I'm gonna make a function
called set uniform Matt for now the
reason I'm calling this set and not
upload because you can see it's called
upload here is because I like to
differentiate it like accordingly so
upload is more of like a API
specifically what we're basically saying
okay you know for OpenGL that'll be like
a GL set uniform Matt for or whatever
Jill uniform at 4 that's the actual Open
GL function that we use to set that
particular uniform where a set is a much
more kind of high-level concept because
that might set it inside a uniform
buffer that might set it individually
we're not really tying this directly to
an OpenGL call whereas this kind of is
so hopefully that clears it up set is
just a much higher level concept and
what it does might depend on a number of
factors whereas upload is pretty simple
upload just literally just uploads it to
the GPU okay cool so we have set uniform
Matt for this of course we don't need a
dynamic class anymore so I'll just
remove it from pretty much everywhere
here and then yeah I mean that's pretty
much it
I'll get rid of these parentheses of
course yeah that's exactly the API that
we're kind of looking for and this of
course also becomes a set uniform Matt
for and in fact it's pretty clear that
if we are setting stuff like that is
gonna be a uniform so we could probably
just trim that as well just just to keep
it really simple here I think that's
important as well because you know in
DirectX for example this would be more
or less like a set constant buffer type
or not necessarily a uniform call and so
because of that I think said Matt 4 is a
little bit like less kind of specific to
particular uniforms and then if I scroll
down I'm gonna do exactly the same thing
here so we'll bind the shader because
that needs to happen and then we will do
let's say yeah flat collar shader set
floor for okay cool so we have this API
here as I've mentioned in the past it's
really really useful for us to actually
be able to write out what it is we want
to do first without specifically making
the API so in other words this is what I
want the API to look like now that I've
written it out it's very easy for me to
go ahead and
those functions so if I pop over to
shader what I'm gonna do is add those
functions in so we've got maybe under
bind and unbind so I'll have a set mat
for for example Const GOM mat for value
zero and then I'll do the same for I
might have flow for and I wanted to add
float free as what just because that's
commonly used and this will be your
vector E of course this will be a black
for alright looks pretty good to me what
I'll do is copy all of these
declarations of course and then take
them into the OpenGL shader class
alright so here we are in OpenGL shader
I'll add these in these will of course
be overrides instead of this equals zero
stuff okay cool looks pretty good to me
so now we'll implement these so popping
over to food needs CPP file I'll just
grab these really quickly let's see
where are we gonna add these so I'll add
them probably well just on the binding
on line because that seems like the
logical place to actually add them in
alright OpenGL shader override that okay
that looks pretty good and of course in
this case all this is gonna do is
basically upload our uniform you know
float 3 so this is super simple of
course what I did was completely forget
about the fact that we need to have a
name so Const si D string and name just
like that because we don't obviously
need well we need to know what what
uniform we're actually setting so I can
tell you I've looked at that let's see
just like that and then in the header
file as well pasting days in okay cool
and then this is just gonna be a name
value so this is super simple in this
case once we do have a material system
these will do something a little bit
different they will actually have to
probably go into the buffer and set the
values accordingly but for this case is
just a simple upload which is nice and
easy okay that's it that's all
have to do to get rid of these penis
completely I'll get rid of these
comments and if we go back into our and
Rho 2 d you should see that we now have
a very simple API here that doesn't need
to include this platform OpenGL shape up
include cool so there we go a little bit
of maintenance and there okay so let's
talk about the elephant to the room so
to speak not that it's particularly
large elephant but we want to be able to
set position and size for our quads if
we launched this engine I should
probably just test out that my changes
didn't break anything first before we
continue so I'm just gonna compile and
run hazel here ok so I did in fact get
build errors so you have a good thing
that I actually test this out okay it's
not happy with GLM apparently we want
including GLM so if I go back to
probably well someplace that does
include GLM such as renderer
2d maybe oh maybe it's orthographic
camera there it is I'll just copy and
paste that include here into where was
this shader that age we need to have
that now
f5 all right and here we have our
initial kind of running program cool so
everything works everything's fine from
here on out we can actually work on the
transforms so going back to render a 2d
let's take a look a bit so currently
we're setting the transform the
transform of course is the kind of
uniform that we want to set if we take a
look at the shader we have our flat
color shader the transformation that
happens here in the vertex shader is we
multiply the view projection matrix by
the transform matrix and then by the
vertex positions so this transform is
that missing piece this is what we
actually want to set up per kind of
rectangle I guess per quod that we draw
and then that will position it
appropriately and this transform of
course is not just a position it's not
like a very or anything like that it's a
mat for which means it can be a full
transform translation rotation and scale
and as mentioned we're going to be
dealing with translation and scale to
set the position and the size of that
quad so going back here what I'll do is
I'll remove this transform from being
set inside the begins same function
because of course this should be
something that gets set per draw server
here in the draw quad what we'll do
is we'll set the map for a transform
over here now we actually have to
calculate the transform so let's do that
so well this is going to be they met for
I'll call the transform and then
basically we're gonna use GLM translate
which I think will probably need to
include from some water like a sandbox
2d matrix transform is the include for
that I'm pretty sure we don't have that
but I might keep it around yeah we don't
so we'll include the matrix transform
here so that we get the function
GLM map for 1.0 is just the identity
matrix that we're starting off with
that's what we're translating and then
we're gonna translate it to each
position and positions already in effect
3 so that's really nice that's all we
have to do now if we want to also have
these size which we do we need to scale
it so I'll just use a GLM scale to
create a scale matrix
GLM map or 1 by 0 F is what we're
starting off with I might just drop this
down here so that it's more visible for
you guys and then what I'll do is of
course convert this size into a scale
basically so we want to scale along the
x and y axes not the z axis so I'll make
a well I can probably just do curly
brackets here as an initializer list so
size X sized or Y and then 0 or sorry
one point syrup for the zest scale so
there we go that is our scale matrix and
we're multiplying that with our
translation matrix you always kind of
want to do it do it in that order
translation times rotation times scale
so for those of you who want to add
rotation add it here and now that we've
got that transform of course we'll just
set it up here might just revert this
back to being all on lines that are
going see it has to be two lines that's
fine and then what we'll do is set that
transform accordingly and I think that's
it that should be everything that we
need so as simple as that we should now
have transforms for all of our quads so
let's test this out by drawing two quads
of course this is just being drawn at 0
0 and with a size of 1 so it should be
absolutely no change but what we'll do
over here is try and maybe well let's
move this back a little bit so maybe
move it back about one on the x-axis
there and I'll reduce the size a little
bit I'll make it like
point eight point eight and I guess we
should also maybe draw something that is
a maybe zero point five and negative
zero point five so we're kind of going
down and then I'll make it non uniform
so I'll make it a little bit taller and
it is wide so maybe 0.5 and 0.75 and
also change the color to test that out
or make it blue so we have a blue so
basically have a red square that's off
to the left and then we should have a
blue rectangle that is off to the kind
of bottom right so let's take a look at
that okay and there we go we have that
red square now off to the left and we
can of course move the camera around and
do everything that we did before and
then we have that blue rectangle off to
the bottom right and that's all there is
to it as you can see it's very very
simple to get transforms working in this
2d renderer now you can position these
any way you like you can set the size to
whatever you like you can expand this to
also include rotation pretty much you
could make some kind of game with this
for sure we have an event system with
like arrow keys for example that we can
use to move all these things around you
could write some kind of behaviour as
well to kind of have like these move by
themselves essentially you could create
a little world if you wanted to you know
you could add some collision detection
just in the kind of in the game layer or
whatever there's a lot you can actually
do with this so go ahead and try it out
if you want to do that and then play
around with this if you can make a
little game with it because we are at
the stage where we could actually do
that now next time I want to talk about
textures because of course these are not
textured yet once we add textures that
will make this a lot more powerful and
yeah I mean we're moving into the space
where we can actually start making games
with this if that is the direction we
want to go and so I want to also mention
that of course this is the very simple
2d renderer for those of you watching
being like this is you know this is
simple stuff yeah we are going to get
into you know making this a lot better
in the future the main problem with this
right now is that we're kind of drawing
each of these quads
like as an individual draw pool which
isn't particularly efficient especially
because if we want to render like a tile
map or something like this which is
common to do in 2d or just a bunch of
text even with text rendering something
we'll have to get to as well that'll be
exciting you know it's it's not
equation to dispatch the more that as a
separate drill said the transform is
very sure cool stuff like that that's
that's more of like a 3d way of
rendering things so we will kind of be
talking about bashing these together
making it lightning fast all that stuff
will come in the future this is kind of
just the beginning of the simple
renderer that we need to make first so
that we can then progress on to the more
kind of advanced 2d renderer anyway hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please hit that like button don't forget
that helped support the series on
patreon and I will see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]